So let's start off really simple. Let's try creating a table to help us out. If
I started with two dimes, then I'd have to have three quarters. For ever two
dimes there's three quarters, so five coins in total. If I add two more dimes,
then I have to add three more quarters. So I'd get ten coins in total. The
ration is a way of representing this constant increase. For every increase of
two in dimes I increase, and three in quarters. I could also have 6 dimes and 9
quarters, which is 15 coins in total. But I don't know which case I'm in. I
could have had any number of coins. So, it's actually impossible to know. And in
fact, I had 10 coins in my hand. For every two dimes, I have three quarters. Two
more dimes, three more quarters. This ratio is constant. I know that last
question wasn't obvious, so don't worry if you didn't get it right. I just
wanted to get you thinking about ratios.